I welcome to monitor as always I am
Peter Ruben senior editor at Wired
magazine this week we're gonna be
talking about a surprisingly good
hip-hop documentary a hack and slash
over-the-top high octane video game I
really did just say high octane didn't I
but first we're gonna talk about a comic
book that's out this week called massive
by Brian Wood who you might know from
his incredible run doing DMZ for vertigo
comics massive is on Dark Horse much
like last week's title that we talked
about it is about the it's kind of an
environmental action story it's about
the crew of iron mental trawler that's
out searching for its lost mate and
piracy and danger and plots and
subterfuge abound Scott Brian woods very
distinctive kind of high-minded really
entertaining storytelling and his
drawing by Christian Donaldson who
actually did a couple of issues of DMZ
back in the day and has done a couple of
other books in the past but it's out
this week definitely worth picking up
and now to talk about video game of the
week we're gonna go to my correspondent
all right so last week we talked about
gravity rush which is a game that's out
this week but is only on the PS Vita
so people with consoles it's called
lollipop chainsaw now if you don't know
anything about lollipop chainsaw there
are two people who came together to make
this game one is his crazy Japanese
developer named suda51 he did a game
called killer 7 he did the No More
Heroes franchise and then the writer is
an American screenwriter named James
Gunn who wrote Don of the dead he wrote
slither he wrote the two scooby-doo
movies but that's really here neither
here nor there so these two came
together and and they wrote a game which
is about a high school cheerleader who
has a chainsaw and a decapitated head of
her zombie boyfriend hanging from her
belt it is alive she gets to use it as a
weapon and all she does is kill zombies
it is a hack and slash par excellence it
is over the top it is blood drenched it
is ridiculous
it is tongue-in-cheek it's really a lot
of fun so by all means pick it up
back to you all right thanks for that
sounds good in the most bizarre way
possible so for movies this week we're
gonna take a turn from the usual popcorn
blockbuster II stuff that we usually
talk about in the summertime just talk
about this fantastic hip hop documentary
that is out this week called the art of
rap and it is directed
strangely enough by ice-t who you know
as a rapper and you know as an actor I
guess but it does a great job with this
he kind of goes across the country
talking to emcees about the art of
hip-hop and how rap has evolved over the
years everyone from kind of old
old-school guys like Grandmaster Caz
through the birth of the new school
Chuck D Karras one through the Golden
Age Redman up through newer guys like
Kanye AMM etc really a really well put
together thing got a ton of access a lot
of great footage it's really fascinating
if you're a tenth the the hip-hop fan
that I really owe to yourself to find
where this is playing and go see it
that's it for the monitor this week we
do have an email address now so hit me
up at the monitor at wired.com you've
got questions if you've got things you
think we should be covering if you love
/ hate what we're doing let us know
but until then then being next week when
we're back with more pop culture stuff
inspirational catch phrase here alright
Riley Riley wake up Riley am I really
that boring
you